Helton is with us in Grand Forks North
Dakota
hey Kelton how are you I'm doing well
thank you for taking my call
sure what's up so my wife and I just
recently got married in July
congratulations thank you
and you just left our parents cellphone
plans and got onto our own plan and what
we found out with Verizon one of the new
things that they've introduced is with a
two-year contract if you pay for your
phone in full upfront then every month
you have an extra $20 charge but if you
do their payment plan and you basically
lease the phone over the teachers and
you don't have to pay that extra $20
charge I think you got that is you know
what there's a random $20 charge for
paying cash for your phone with Verizon
yeah I'm pretty sure I don't pay that
dude I have a verizon account with I
don't know one hundred and fifty two
hundred phones on it and pretty sure I'm
not paying twenty bucks a phone and we
pay cash for them I think you need to
revisit I think you need to revisit your
information here there's no possible way
I'm paying a premium to them because I
paid cash for my phone and if that's the
case go to a go to a go to Sprint or
t-mobile or somebody if Verizon is that
stupid and I don't think they are no
you'd never lease a stupid cell phone
translation you can't afford a cell
phone if that's what the case is so now
you pay cash for your phones or you
don't buy them don't get on their list
don't get on their lease plans you're
that that's a it's a scam the lease
plans are horrible but no I haven't seen
the twenty dollar surcharge that's a new
thing I've not heard of but good lord
what a horrible idea and yeah I can
promise you it's costing you more in
twenty bucks if you lease it a whole
bunch more hey guys thanks for watching
if you enjoyed this video
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show